in this video we are going to give
ourselves an overview of ancient egypt
which corresponds geographically pretty
closely to the modern day state of egypt
in north east africa
now the central feature in both ancient
egypt and in modern egypt is the nile
river that you see in blue right over
here
and the nile river is one of the great
rivers of the world it rivals the amazon
river it's the longest river it sources
the the tributaries of the nile river
start even south of this picture and the
water flows northward and eventually its
delta reaches the mediterranean sea the
delta which is where a river opens into
the sea is called a delta because as you
can see these rivers you can even see it
from the satellite pictures right over
here they start branching up a bunch and
you have this upside down triangular
region which looks a little bit like an
upside down greek letter delta so that's
why river delta is called that and that
this one just happens to be upside down
if it was flowing the other way it would
be a right side up delta
so the nile river it flows from you
could say
eastern mid africa
up into the mediterranean sea and
because it has this northward flow the
southern parts of the river are up river
and they are actually called the upper
nile
so upper
the upper nile is actually south of the
lower nile
of the lower nile and once again that's
because the upper nile is upriver it's
also flowing from higher elevations to
lower elevations so as you go south you
get to higher and higher elevations
now the reason why the river is so
important we study this multiple times
rivers are source of fresh water when
they flood they make the surrounding
soil fertile they're suitable for
agriculture and the nile valley is one
of the first places that we see
agriculture emerging during the
neolithic period in fact human
settlement we believe was wrong along
this nile river valley as far as 6 000
6000 bce or 8 000 years ago and it might
have been there even further back in
time and because you had that
agriculture it allowed for higher
population densities which allowed for
more specialization of labor and more
complex societies it's not a coincidence
that some of the first that one of the
first great civilizations emerged here
now our story of the nile river or
of egypt and actually there they are
tied very closely even though egypt is
considered a lot of this region the
most of the human population this is
true even today is right along
is right along the river around that
fertile soil where where
where the agriculture actually occurs in
fact this was so important to the
ancient egyptians that their whole
calendar their seasons were based on
what the nile river was doing they had a
season called the inundation or the
flooding of the river which makes the
soil fertile they had a season of growth
which is now talking about the growth of
the crops and they have a season of
harvest and so you had people in this
valley
for thousands of years but when we talk
about ancient egypt we formally talk
about it as a civilization around 30 100
30 31 50 bce
and this is where we get to our timeline
right over here so we're talking about
right around there on our timeline and
the reason why this is considered the
beginning of the ancient egyptian
civilization is this is when we believe
that upper upper and lower egypt were
first united under the king and there's
different names used narmer sometimes
or menes
minas i'm going to mispronounce things
every now and then and i'm probably
doing it here as well and so he he was a
king that unified
upper and lower egypt into an empire
and the empire as we'll see which lasts
thousands of years every one of these
spaces is a hundred years so we're going
to go over a huge time span but the the
the ancient egyptian civilization is
roughly divided into three kingdoms you
have the old kingdom which went from
about
right from about the 27th century bce
up to about the 17th century bce you
have the middle kingdom and you have the
new kingdom and once again this is about
this is spanning right over here over a
thousand years of history and in between
those you have these intermediate
periods where the kingdom or the empire
was a little bit more fragmented you
have in some of these intermediate
periods you have some foreign rule
but just to get a sense of
some of what happened over the thousands
of years and i'm kind of laughing in my
head because it's it's hard to cover
over you know two three thousand years
in the course of just a few minutes but
this will give you a sense of what
ancient egyptian civilization was all
about
now the kings are referred to as
pharaohs but as we'll see that term
pharaoh was not really used until we get
to the new kingdom but i'll refer to the
kings as pharaohs throughout this video
just to say hey these are the egyptian
kings and the old the old kingdom is
probably most known today in our popular
culture for what we most associate with
ancient egypt and that is the pyramids
and here right over here are the
pyramids there's a great pyramid of giza
of giza which is near modern day cairo
today this is the sphinx and they were
built in that old period under
the pharaohs sneferu and khufu right
over here in the 26th century
right over here in the 26th century bce
and we are still trying to get a better
understanding of how this was done we
actually now don't believe that it was
done by slave labor but instead it was
done during you could say the off season
by the peasants as a form of taxation
okay you're done planting or harvesting
your
crops well now that you have some time
and this shows actually the importance
of agriculture for for freeing people up
so to speak why don't you help the
pharaohs build these massive tombs which
i've seen various estimates that might
have taken someplace between 10 and 100
000 people several decades to build each
but these are even today these were
built
over 4 500 years ago are some of the
most iconic symbols that humanity has
ever created and the reason why we know
so much about ancient egypt ancient
egyptian or ancient egypt is that we
have been able to decipher their writing
it's a symbolic they have these
pictographs these hieroglyphics i'm sure
you've heard of the word before and for
a while we had no idea what what they
said we would see these inscriptions in
these tombs and we we had a sense that
okay these tombs especially things like
the pyramids would be for these great
kings you could we could tell that it
was a stratified society that nobility
had better tombs than others but we
didn't really have a good sense of what
was going on until we discovered this
which is the rosetta stone which was
discovered in 1799
and why the the reason why this is so
valuable is it has the same text written
in three different languages it has it
written in
the hieroglyphs of the ancient egyptians
and it has it written in a later script
used in egypt called demotic egyptian
and most importantly it has it also
written in greek
and so
historians were able to say okay we can
now start to decipher what these symbols
mean because we have a translation of
them and that's why it's one of the
first civilizations where we're able to
put picture put the put the picture
together and hieroglyphics are one of
the first forms of writing
but let's now go on in our in our
journey through thousands of years of
ancient egyptian civilization you
between the old kingdom you ha and the
middle kingdom you have the first
intermediate period then you have the
middle kingdom and then you have the
hixos which are semitic people semitic
referring to their language being of the
same family as semitic languages like
arabic or hebrew or aramaic but then you
have the new kingdom and the new kingdom
is considered to be the peak of ancient
egypt it's really the height of their
technology it's the height of their
military capability and there are
several pharaohs that are worthy of note
in the new kingdom the first is
he was born
amen hotep or he was originally known as
amin otep iv and then he eventually
names himself akinaten and akhenaten
means effective for otton otten being a
signific a significant egyptian god
and the reason why he changed his name
is he decides that okay we have that the
egyptians have this huge this huge
pantheon of gods here's just some of
them right over here this is the god
osiris often associated with the
afterlife or transition or
transition regeneration
resurrection you have the god aman here
and his first name amen otep it means
amen amen is satisfied what is
considered kind of the equivalent of
zeus you have the god here horus once
again a very significant god at
different times in egypt but what was
interesting about aminotep iv or
akhenaten whichever name you want to use
is he decided no no
i don't like this pantheon this
polytheistic
religion that we have i want to worship
one god and the god that he decides to
worship is really the you could consider
it the sun god or the sun disk and its
representation looks something like this
and it was referred to
as
aten and so he changes his name to akin
aten and he actually starts to try to
get rid of evidence of these other gods
or
to make them a lot less important
and so the reason why that's notable is
this is viewed as one of perhaps one of
the first attempts at monotheism at
least within the at least within this
ancient egyptian civilization he's also
noted for giving a lot of power to his
wife to the queen nefertiti who
some people say was second in command or
even co-ruled alongside him now he was
also famous because after his death
eventually his son king tut tutankhamun
comes to power and the reason why king
tut as he's often known although it's
tootin common is is known is because we
were able to find his his his tombs in
in a relatively good order and so it's
become a popular
he's become a
a
a popular part of the imagination and
he's known as a child pharaoh he comes
to power when he's very young he dies at
18 and so it's kind of an interesting
story
now most prominent amongst all of the
pharaohs
across egyptian history and this is also
in the new kingdom comes a little bit
after tutankhamen is ramses ii and
ramses ii who emerges here in the 13th
century and he rules for most of the
13th century bce he represents really
the peak of
egypt ancient egypt as a military power
he's famous for his the battle at kadesh
which is the earliest battle where we
actually know what the tactics and the
formations were and it was with the also
significant hittite empire in 1274 bce
this is an image drawn much much later
of the battle of kadesh the battle we
now believe might have been a bit of a
stalemate ramses the second wasn't able
to capture kadesh but has told us a lot
about military tactics and strategy and
formation of that time
historians today think it might be the
largest chariot battle maybe ever so
this was a significant thing that
happened now eventually the new kingdom
does collapse as we get to the end of
the second millennium and then over the
next several hundreds of years we're
talking about a very long period of time
you it gets fragmented you have several
rulers you have the cushites rule from
upper from the upper nile the cushites
were in this area
right over here they rule for a brief
period the assyrians that's a
mesopotamian civilization they rule for
a small period of time and then
eventually and we talk about this in
some detail in other videos you have the
persians take over you have canvases the
cyrus the great sun he's able to rule
over he's able to conquer egypt and
egypt becomes part of the kheminid
empire for a while until the conquering
of alexander the great and after
alexander the great dies one of his
generals and his dynasty takes over
ptolemaic egypt and now it's being ruled
by foreign well it's been ruled by
foreigners for a while now but now it's
by the greeks and the famous cleopatra
who's considered a pharaoh of egypt
she's actually greek by blood she is
actually the one that seduced you could
say
julius caesar and mark anthony and after
cleopatra's death more and more or
eventually it becomes part of rome so as
you can see we covered this enormous
large
time period in history one of the most
significant civilizations in all of
history one of the most famous poems
about civilizations and rulers about
ramses ii the poem ozymandias was named
after him you have some of the great
cities of the ancient world thebes which
was the capital during parts of the new
kingdom in the middle kingdom you have
memphis which was one of the some people
say founded by manis
and the capital of the old kingdom these
were all happening in ancient egypt